Congratulations.
You now have a server updated and
configured, sitting out there on
the wild west that is the internet.
Best of all, you can rest easy at night
knowing your server is safe and secure.
Where you do go from here?
It depends on your needs.
There are a lot of different
types of servers, email servers,
chat servers, web application servers.
Generally, the only big
differences between each of these
is the software they have installed and
the ports that they have open.
I've placed a few server set-up walk
throughs in the instructor notes below,
that should get you started.
I'd encourage you to start by
setting up a web application server,
installing Apache in a database
server like PostgreSQL.
Good luck, have fun, and
remember, experiment.
This is your own little
piece of the Internet.